lakers started off poorly against the
raptors as well as davis hits that
raptors actually scored the first 13
points jazz here tonight the first seven
points
multiple quick decision and quick passes
a second drive and a lob to go bear
davis
and the foul there
and then would you go back go bear
because
in a left-hand layup as davis gets a
steal
well davis is as a defender as quinn
snyder
needs a timeout gets across the lane
comes up short though
davis quick outlet to lebron james
james behind the back goes up under and
lays it in
clarkson comes up short over mistimed
his jump and here comes caruso
caldwell pope floats it up and an easy
two for anthony davis
for them going forward and trying to win
a championship as jeff mentioned
depleted already because of
rondo and bradley and davis comes flying
in kind of an awkward landing
but it's their whole demeanor
their fight their grit that's better oh
neo shot blocked by james
terrific rejection so neil well good
attack by
o'neal a better block by james
he spiked that into the backboard
james one one-on-one with niang
goes right at him and finishes he just
makes those moves looks so easy
again he loves to finish with his right
hand even though he's a left-hander
great floating and davis running the
floor
good push by the lakers wrong-footed
left-handed finish
and on the court as well james drives
and finishes only his sixth field goal
attempt but did that one with authority
and it's back to four
defense is a tough business right now in
the nba
oh that's a beautiful pass by mitchell
davis gets inside and banks at home
should happen you see anthony davis here
with a good block
he had to meet gordon chiesa
for waiters it's only the sixth game
he's played all season
third with the lakers anthony davis
knocks down another
one and they shoot it look at where he
is brett brown was the first one i saw
who basically in practice instituted a
four-point line
so that they could shoot from deeper
which helped with their spacing
and you could see how they got better by
keeping those habits and routines
well this year's mets have kept the same
habits they keep losing mike that's your
mets team
wanted to see the open man and he's
found him davis
step back three bang and the foul
anthony davis capping off a brilliant
night
with a chance for a four-point play you
know this league has changed
[Music]
big-time shot and if he knocks down this
free throw a
40-point game for anthony davis